after the unexpected death of her lover
martha discovers a strange service that
generates interactions with someone who
has died today on cinema recapped i'll
show you
be right back from netflix
this is an episode of a series called
black mirror which begins with a man
named ash
in a car waiting for his partner named
martha she arrives with some coffees in
both hands so she can't open the door
and ash doesn't help her because he's
distracted with his phone
she yells at him so he quickly opens it
martha starts the car and drives home
while they have fun singing together
however ash doesn't like the next song
so he turns off the radio and martha
gets upset so they both start arguing
about the musical genres they like when
they get home ash uses his phone to take
a picture of a painting and post it on
his social networks martha gets upset
again since ash is always distracted
with the phone that night they have sex
but the woman doesn't look satisfied and
stays thoughtful in bed the next day
when they're in the kitchen ash asks her
to accompany him since they have to
return a rented car but martha tells him
she'll not be able to because she has a
lot of work ash gets in the vehicle to
return it so he leaves home while martha
works as an artist
using her drawing tablet at night ash
hasn't arrived yet so the girl starts
calling him to find out why he hasn't
come home but it doesn't answer
she decides to call the car rental
company to see if they know anything of
him although they tell him that he never
returned the vehicle
she calls family and friends but nobody
knows anything
then she sees a police patrol arriving
their home
and gets scared she opens the door to
the officers and finds out that her
lover died in an accident the next day
martha is at the funeral where her
friend tries to reassure her but martha
just tells her to shut up however the
woman offers her a way to talk to her
husband explaining that while it is not
exactly the same it could help martha
doesn't want to listen to her anymore so
she yells at her to shut up and the
situation the funeral becomes awkward
for everyone a few days later martha is
alone at home
still sad for having lost her lover
and one day like any other she finds
messages from her friend sarah who tells
her that she signed her up for a beta
martha ignores her but shortly
afterwards receives a message from
someone who has the same name as her
husband
so she quickly dials her friend to
complain about it since she doesn't like
that they use their husband's name to
send messages the friend tells her that
it's just technology which thanks to the
information they have about him from his
social networks allowed them to make a
copy of ash so she can send messages and
he will answer as if you were the real
one sarah tries to convince her that
it's a good option for her to be calmer
and she also tells her that if she
allows them to access his mail and
personal things her husband's copy will
be even more real martha stays
thoughtful for a moment
and then hangs up the phone the next day
martha feels nauseous and vomits in the
bathroom
she takes a pregnancy test which is
positive
and gets scared then martha finally
makes up her mind and decides to start
chatting with her husband's copy
so she looks for his messages and
connects with him telling him that she's
pregnant and sees that he really answers
as if it were the real ash so martha
cries and gets emotional shortly after a
family member dials her to see how she's
doing but she evades them so they don't
go see her since she wants to be alone
chatting with the virtual ash one day
she tells him that she wishes she could
talk to him
so ash tells her that they can do that
but she has to send him a lot of audio
and video so that he can clone the voice
in the way he speaks
martha shares many audios that she had
stored on her phone so after a few
moments she receives a call which seems
to come from ash she answers the phone
and finds out that it is indeed the
identical voice for lover they start to
talk and martha notices that the virtual
ash even makes the same jokes as the
original
the days go by and martha gets used to
talking to him daily
one day
she sees her baby during an ultrasound
so she records the heartbeat
sends the audio to ash and they both get
excited however at that moment martha
accidentally drops her phone so she
starts to get hysterical since she's
broken it and lost communication with
ash later martha arrives home with a new
device
so she puts it on charge and quickly
receives a call from ash
she answers and the man tells her to
calm down
since he's in the cloud
so he can't be destroyed as easily as
breaking a phone ash tells her that
there's something he has to tell her
but it may be expensive
since it's one more level of the beta
that's to make a clone identical to him
and they can send it to her in a package
a few days later a delivery truck
arrives at martha's house so she
receives a huge sealed box and tells the
workers where to put it as soon as the
delivery men leave martha quickly opens
the box and sees a frozen body inside
while ash tells her on the phone that
his body is not ready yet he tells her
that she has to leave it in warm water
in the bathtub and she has to add the
vitamin electrolyte sachets that came in
the box
and then she has to let it rest for a
few hours the woman follows the
instructions and leaves the bathroom
talking on the phone with ash while she
waits
and after a while the man tells her that
he has to hang up since he will begin to
synchronize with the clone then martha
is left alone so she begins to feel
nervous since noises are heard in the
bathroom but she remembers that ash told
her not to interrupt the process
later martha hears the door opening and
then sees someone coming down the stairs
so she notices that the clone is exactly
the same as her deceased husband however
martha is somewhat afraid of him since
she knows that he is not the original
despite the fact that he speaks jokes
and behaves in every way like her lover
she decides to have a drink so she takes
some courage and begins to approach ash
noticing that there are certain details
that could not be cloned but even so
he's almost identical she tells him that
she misses him
and starts kissing him
and shortly after they take off their
shirts and martha starts asking him to
go to bed with her
but ash tells her that he has no records
of how to behave with her in bed so
she'll have to show
then while they're doing it we see that
this time martha is enjoying the act
when they finish she asks how he does it
so well
so ash tells her that that's how he was
programmed since he was trained with
adult videos that were shown to him by
his programmers the next day martha
wakes up and gets scared since she sees
ash who is not moving and his eyes are
open but the man reassures her saying
that he doesn't need to sleep if she
wants he can close his eyes during the
night later martha is working on one of
her drawings when she notices that a car
arrives at the house and sees that one
of her sisters is coming so she quickly
tells ash to hide in a room since she
prefers to keep him secret then martha
receives her sister so they start
talking about how her relatives were
worried about her since she hardly
answers the messages
at night the sister leaves and tells her
to please keep her posted martha drinks
some water and ash arrives
then she gets upset since she thinks
that what she is doing is wrong
when they go to sleep the woman tells
him to at least pretend to sleep and
breathe like a normal person however
marsha loses patience so she tells ash
to go out of the room
but she goes after him and starts
fighting since she considers that his
behavior is not the same as out of the
original ash he asks her if she wants
him to fight back
since he has a very extensive catalogue
of rudeness but the woman gets even
angrier and pushes him out of the house
the next day we see that ash spent the
night outside
not far from the house since he cannot
go more than 25 meters away from the
house or from his administrator so he
asks her to please let him in and martha
allows it ash goes in to change his
clothes since martha will take him for a
walk she takes him to the edge of a
cliff and orders him to jump
and ash is determined to obey but martha
tells him that the original ash would
have begged not to
so he begins to beg obeying everything
his administrator tells him to do martha
gets even more desperate and screams and
anger into the air a few years later
we see that martha's daughter is growing
up
and her mother celebrates one of her
birthdays
and gives her a slice of cake
but the girl asks her to give her
another so she can take it to the attic
where martha keeps ash locked up and
only allows her daughter to see him
every now and then the end
if you liked the video please leave a
like and subscribe to continue receiving
the recaps the best sci-fi series and
movies thanks for watching